vielleicht kannst du als aller erstes
mal sagen was geht durch den kopf von
dir von vielen seiner mitschüler wenn
sie hören ab und zu mal aufstehen und in
die hände klatschen hilft schon
ja hallo erstmal freut mich heute dabei
zu sein
naja erstmal natürlich doch ablehnung
das scheint doch ein sehr sehr schlecht
gemeint schlecht platzierten scherz
gewesen zu sein als es muss klar sein
dass das absolut nicht funktional ist
dass die situation in den schulen
dramatisch ist und vor allen dingen dass
wir da eben mehr veränderungen brauchen
und vor allen dingen das eben in den
letzten monaten da was verschlafen
worden ist weil fakt ist es hat sich in
den letzten wochen am morgen kaum
besseren verändert und es gibt einfach
probleme beispiel digitalisierung die
wohnen seit jahren verschlafen und
besonders im bereich des
gesundheitsschutzes fenster aufmachen
alleine ist keine lösung das führt er
dazu dass es im frust gibt in der
schülerschaft frau busse wie ist das bei
ihnen an der schule müssen die schüler
vor dem unterricht oder im unterricht
kniebeugen machen ein bisschen die hände
reiben damit es warm bleibt
nein nicht aus den gründen weil sie
frieren vielleicht noch um die
rhythmisierung der stunde zu haben wenn
man alle 20 minuten lüftet 45 minuten
und dann wieder die fenster schließt
also wir sind noch nicht erfroren
wir tragen das mit fassung richard wie
siehst du das machen die kollegen an den
schulen bei dir das auch gut oder wie
siehst du das
ich muss leider ein bisschen
widersprechen weil meine große hoffnung
ist es eben dass es nicht so wird wie
anfang des jahres ich hatte ganz viele
lehrer die als toll gemacht ich bis
jetzt ganz viel lehrer die kümmern sich
ganz toll aber in aller ehrlichkeit es
gibt einen großen teil der lehrerschaft
gar nichts und das waren bei mir lehrer
die haben sich im ersten doktor wochen
dann gar nicht gemeldet das sind lehrer
die sind wenn man heute in quarantäne
sind so dass sie ein paar arbeitsblätter
schicken aber wer denkt dass ernsthaft
ein paar arbeitsblätter ohne weitere
materialien ohne erklärung ein
unterricht ersetzen könnten den kann ich
ganz klar sagen der befindet sich auf
einen trugschluss denn das ganze braucht
eben wirklich ein unterrichts
ersatzmaterialien bereitstellen wie es
in vielen schon passiert dass das reicht
lange nicht außen deshalb denke ich dass
wir da hat deutlich mehr unterstützung
für schülerinnen und schüler zu hause
brauchen jedes dritte kind in berlin
lebt in armut das sind die schüler die
keine unterstützung zu hause bekommen
die dürfen eben nicht zurückgelassen
werden ich sehe die gefahr dass das bei
so einem weiteren doktor wenn er so wie
im frühjahr kommt doch passieren könnte
da bedarf es deutlicher vorkehrungen
zwar jetzt schon wir sind bild und wir
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren